The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we're
going to dig a little deeper
into the system that
we've been talking about.
So we've already talked about
source coding and source
decoding.
And then we talked
about channel coding
as we've just finished talking
about block codes and Viterbi--
convolutional codes
and Viterbi decoding.
So that's the coding
here and the decoding.
And now we're going to
drill down to the next level
to start to talk about
the actual signals going
across physical channels.
So this is going to
actually extend over
the entire next
module of the course.
I want to describe this in
the context of something
you're going to be doing
in labs 4 through 6.
You're actually
going to experiment
with a specific channel.
What you'll have is bits coming
in, code words coming in,
being translated to signals.
In this case,
discrete time signals,
and I'll give you an
example shortly of that.
The signals will then be
adapted through the modulator
for transmission on
an analog channel.
So there's a modulation
process and there's
a digital-to-analog
conversion process.
You'll be generating
waveform that you apply
to the speaker in your laptop.
That's going to
be a transmitter.
The channel is going to
be just the air around you
with all the disturbances
of room acoustics and noise
and all of that, all the
distortions from that.
And then you'll
pick up the signal
on the microphone on your
laptop or an external microphone
if you want.
Conversion from analog
to digital, demodulation
and filtering to
undo the modulation,
and we'll be talking
about this in more detail
to get another
sequence of samples.
After which you
have a decision rule
that then looks at the samples
and says, did I get a 0 or a 1?
And you spit out the
bits of your code word.
OK, so this is what we're
going to be looking at.
So here is what you
might be sending
at the transmitting end.
You've got the bits coming in.
You're going to convert
them to signals,
and we're going to think
of discrete time signals.
So this is a signal x of
n-- n takes integer value,
so that's my
discrete time clock.
And the typical waveform
might look like this.
I might decide just very simply
to have levels held at 0.5 for,
let's say, 16 samples
per bit, and then held
at 0 for 16 samples to denote
a 1 and a 0 respectively.
So here's a 1, a 00, 111, 0101.
So we're converting two samples.
This is a sample number,
and then the next step
will be to actually--
in your computer you'll
send this to your digital
to analog converter which will--
with a particular clock cycle,
convert this to real time.
What you might imagine is
that the actual waveform that
goes out on the
channel is somehow
related to the
continuous waveform
that you get by just connecting
the tops of these discrete time
values.
The actual mechanism for
transmission through the air
we'll talk about next time.
So right now we're
just going to focus
on the level of the
discrete time signals.
And at the other end, after
you've done your transmissions
through the channel and you've
demodulated and filtered,
you get a sequence
which ideally is
a replication of the
sequence that you sent in.
It can't have a scale factor,
scale factors don't worry us.
In this case, you see that
the amplitude is divided by 2.
But basically you see
the trace of what was
sent at the transmitting end.
There's some distortion
that's introduced
by the dynamics of
the channel, and we'll
be talking about that
in more detail later.
So we aren't getting
quite the straight edges.
But after a brief
transient period,
the waveform seems to
settle to the constant value
that we had of the input.
So this is our received
set of samples.
Now in this figure, I've
assumed that there's
no noise, only the distortion.
This lecture is going
to be about the noise.
I wanted you to get the sense
of what distortion does,
and then we'll park that issue
and come back to it next time
and actually for several
lectures after that.
But this lecture we're
going to focus on noise.
Before we look at noise,
this is what a noise-free
received signal might look like
with just the distortion in it.
OK.
And now you've got to
convert to a bit sequence.
So a simple way to do that
is pick an appropriate point
in each bit slot.
Each slot of 16 samples long.
Pick an appropriate
point, taking
account of these
transient effects
and so on, and then sample.
And if the sample value
is above a threshold,
you'll declare a 1.
If the sample values below the
threshold, you'll declare a 0.
And so you reconstruct
the sequence that went in.
So we have the sample and
threshold feature here.
So we're just taking one of
the samples in the bit period,
comparing with the threshold,
and making a declaration.
That's a very simple-minded
decision rule.
OK.
So we'll come back
to distortion.
Today I want to
talk about noise,
and I want to then
suppress distortion.
So let's forget
about distortion.
Let's assume that
the received signal
yn is exactly what was sent
except for some additive noise.
So what we're
imagining is you send
a nice clean set of samples
here into your digital-to-analog
converter, and what
comes out ideally
would be the same
set of samples,
but actually what happens is
that each of these samples
is perturbed by noise.
And so you get something
that might look like this.
OK, so this is y, then, and
what we had before was x of n.
OK.
So nominally you'd
get the same thing.
The only thing
that's different now
is you've got an additive noise.
We're going to assume
that this noise sample
wn is independent from
one sample to the next.
So when the channel
and the processing
and so on decides to put
a noise sample on this,
it doesn't pay attention
to what noise sample was
out of on either side.
So every noise sample
is picked independently.
And it's picked from
the same distribution.
That's with the identically
distributed part of this mean.
So the characteristics
of the noise
are the same right
through our signal.
That's what we're assuming.
That's the identically
distributed part.
It's a statement about the
stationarity of the noise
characteristics.
All of this can be
generalized, but this
is where we're going
to have our story
and that's all we're
going to consider.
OK, a key metric,
then, is what's
the signal-to-noise ratio?
This is something that you see
all over the place, the SNR.
Usually what people
mean is signal power,
and power is usually the
square of a signal-- that's
what you're thinking of.
If you think of
voltages, for instance,
the square of the voltage gives
you power in the resistor.
So you think of the
signal as being x,
Its power as being x squared.
Except you've got
to decide, do you
want to talk about the peak
power or the time average power
or some other measurement
of the signal power?
So that's the signal
part of this ratio.
And then the noise part of the
ratio is the noise variance.
So we have a noise
component wn, it's
the expected squared
amplitude of that.
Oh, by the way, I didn't--
this is on my slide,
but I didn't say it yet.
I'm going to assume
the noise is zero mean.
Which means that these
excursions from what
you expect on average are at 0.
If there was a systematic
bias to the noise,
if I knew that there
was a non-zero mean,
I could just factor
that into my processing
and think of my
expected received signal
as taking account of
that non-zero mean.
So there's no loss of
generality, really.
I'm assuming a zero mean noise.
OK.
Now when you come to
actually computing numbers,
this is another example--
showing another
kind of waveform,
this is the sum of
sinusoids, I assume,
to which you're
adding some noise.
And in this
particular simulation,
by tweaking the value
of A there, that's the--
it's a gain factor
on the signal.
You can actually vary
the signal-to-noise ratio
and get a feel for
what difference
signal-to-noise
ratio is represented.
So at high
signal-to-noise ratio,
the noise isn't perturbing
what went down very much.
But when you get the lower
signal-to-noise ratios,
the noise is actually
distorting the signal
that you started with
quite substantially.
Now the SNR here is
described in dB, decibels.
And so let me just
say a word about that.
That's a unit you'll
see all the time.
You've seen all the time.
So we're really
trying to measure
a signal-to-noise ratio.
So this is what you
would normally think of.
But in many applications,
a logarithmic scale
is really what you
want to deal with.
For instance, if
you're measuring
the response of the ear
to noise intensities,
it turns out there's a
logarithmic feature built
into our sensors.
So usually want to be measuring
power and power ratios
in terms of a log scale.
That should have had
a capital B there.
So here's the definition
of what a ratio is on dB.
It's the ratio log to
the base 10 times 10.
One caution here.
I told you that when
we talk about powers,
that's the square
of the amplitude.
So if you're going to
compare amplitudes,
ratio of amplitudes
on a log scale, then
actually what you end
up doing is taking 20
log 10 ratio of amplitudes.
So you'll sometimes see
this definition as 20 log
to the base 10
ratio of amplitudes,
and what people are doing, then,
is comparing amplitude ratios,
not power ratios.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Why do we define
power as amplitude squared?
PROFESSOR: In sum--
so the question was,
why do we define power
as amplitude squared?
If you think of an
electrical circuit
with some signal
applied across it,
a voltage, the
instantaneous power
dissipated in the
resistor is given by that.
So people start to think of
square of a quantity as power.
In the continuous
time domain that's
very natural in signals
that come from physics,
and that terminology is
just being carried over
to this kind of a
discrete time setting.
So when people say power, they
mean square of the signal.
It could've been
called something else.
OK.
So you can actually span
huge ratios in power
on this log scale with much
more better behaved numbers.
0 dB, then, is a ratio of 1.
3 dB, this is good to
carry around in your head.
3 dB, it's actually
3.01-something,
but 3 dB is a factor of
2 on the power ratio,
or square root of 2
on an amplitude ratio.
So let's actually go
back to what I showed you
on the previous slide.
So here, for instance,
is an SNR of 0.4 dB.
If I figure that
that's close to 0 dB,
then I should expect that
the noise power and signal
power are about equal, and
the noise amplitude and signal
amplitude are about equal.
So what I expect to
see is perturbations
of the original signal
that are comparable
with the signal
values themselves,
and that's sort of
what we see here.
The shape of the signal is
pretty distorted at this point
because the typical
amplitude of the noise sample
is comparable with the signal
sample that I'm interested in.
OK, so when you
get to 0 dB, you're
starting to get quite
disturbed-looking waveforms.
When you have 20 dB in
power, that's actually 100--
ratio of 100--
sorry, what is that?
Yeah, that's a ratio
of 100, isn't it?
On par?
So it's a ratio of
10 on amplitudes,
and that's what you're seeing.
The noise excursions
are about a 10th of what
the signal amplitudes are.
All right.
It takes a little getting used
to, but it's fairly standard.
OK.
So now we want to figure
out how to describe
noise and work with it.
So let's look at a typical
run of a noise sequence.
What I've done is just
extracted the noise piece
of a typical received signal.
So it's got excursions
above and below 0.
Remember, I said it was a zero
mean random variable that we're
thinking of, zero mean noise.
And you can describe how these
values are distributed by just
doing a simple histogram.
And if you only take a few
values like 100 samples,
you get a pretty
messy-looking histogram,
it doesn't seem to
have much structure.
But as you take more
and more samples,
you'll typically find that the
histogram actually settles out
to a nice shape, to some
subtle kind of shape.
Normalizing this to
have unit area under it
gives you what's called
the probability density
function for the noise.
So this is a term--
kind of notion that's critical
in working with noise.
So here's a step
of idealization.
We're stepping back from
thinking about histograms
to just a mathematical
way of talking
about how random quantities
distribute themselves.
So we'll talk about--
by the way, we've been
using W for the noise
and X for the signal, but if
you look in probability books,
the first variable that people--
the first symbol people reach
for and they want to talk
about a random variable is X,
and I got stuck with a
whole bunch of figures that
had X in them, so I didn't
want to change it to W.
This is anything.
We're going to
apply it to our W,
but for now it's some capital
X. The other convention
when you talk about
random variables
as you tend to use a
capital letter to denote
the random variable.
OK.
So we say that X is a
random variable governed
by a particular probability
density function.
If you can compute
the probability
that X lies in some
particular interval
by taking the corresponding
area under that PDF.
So the PDF is the object
that gives you probabilities
from areas under the integrals.
So if you want the probability
that the quantity X,
take the numerical values
in this range, X1 to X2,
then you integrate
the PDF from X1 to X2,
and this area is what you call--
that area is the probability.
And the total area under
the PDF, of course,
has to be 1 because
the probability
that X lies somewhere is 1.
The probability that X
takes some value is 1.
So this is how we
work with PDFs.
Again, you'll find when
people want to sketch a PDF,
the reflex is to sketch one
of these bell-shaped things.
And it turns out there's
actually a reason for that.
This bell-shaped thing or a
specific bell-shaped thing
called the Gaussian
tends to arise
in all sorts of
applications, and that's
a consequence of something
called the central limit
theorem.
This is considered one of
the most important results
in probability theory.
It actually dates back to about
the 1730s as a conjecture,
but it was Laplace who--
in I guess the late 1700s, early
1800s who actually proved it.
And it wasn't actually called
the central limit theorem
until much more recently,
till about 1930 or so.
And was called that because
it was the limit theorem that
was central to all
of probability,
that was the thinking.
So here is the
central limit theorem.
It says that if you
sum up a whole bunch
of little random quantities that
are not necessarily Gaussian,
and if they each have finite
mean and finite variance,
the sum is going to have a
distribution that's going
to look increasingly Gaussian.
So you could start,
for instance,
with a random variable that's
described by this triangular
PDF.
Take a whole bunch of
random variables generated
according to that PDF.
When I say generated according
to that PDF, what I mean
is that the probability that
you get a value between any two
limits here is the area under
that piece of the triangle.
Generate a whole bunch of
these and sum them together,
you find that the
resulting histogram
starts to look Gaussian.
You can start with another
kind of distribution,
and again, it starts
to look Gaussian.
And the more of these you add,
the more it looks Gaussian.
And so this can be
actually made very precise.
There's a very
precise sense in which
the limiting distribution
in a situation like this
is a Gaussian.
So what is a Gaussian?
I've got to describe
that for you.
I'll do it in more
detail in a second.
First, let me tell you
how we defined these two
key parameters.
These are things that from
other sorts of contexts.
The mean and the standard
deviation of the variance,
you know it from
quiz scores at least,
but here is the mathematical
definition in terms of a PDF.
So if you have a PDF for a
random variable capital X,
the mean value of capital X is--
it's basically the
average value of X
weighted by the probability,
which is what you expect.
So it's X times
the PDF integrated
over all possible values.
That's the definition
of the expected value.
And what we do when we
take the expected value
of the mean value on a quiz is
a sort of discrete time version
of this.
So we're seeing how many
people in a particular bin
and multiply by the score
for the people in that bin
and sum over all possible bins.
That's one way to think
of what this is doing,
assuming you've got the right
normalization of the PDF.
And the variance is the
expected squared deviation
from the mean value.
So here's a deviation
You square it, and now you want
to take its expected value,
so you weight it by the
PDF of X and that gives you
the variance.
So the variance is the
expected squared deviation
from the mean value.
OK, so the PDF is valuable
in getting all of this.
And to get a sense of what
means and standard deviations
and variances do--
I don't know if I said from
the previous slide, by the way,
that standard deviation is the
square root of the variance.
Did I say that?
Maybe not.
But I have it at the
bottom of the slide, right?
OK.
So shifting the mean
of a random variable,
if I define a new random
variable with the same PPF
except for a different
mean, what that means
is that-- what that signifies
is that the PDF has just
shifted over by that amount.
So changing the mean
and nothing else
will just shift the PDF over
to the corresponding position.
Changing the variance from a
small value to a large value
will spread out the
PDF because you're
the variance is capturing the
expected squared deviation
from the mean.
So a higher variance PDF has
got to have a larger spread.
But because the areas
normalized to 1,
if it spreads out this way,
it's got to come down on top,
and that's what
you're seeing here.
All these pictures
actually turn out
to be drawn for the
Gaussian, but my statements
are more general here.
But here's the Gaussian itself.
So now I'm going
back to my notation
W. We're going to think
of a random variable
W which is going to be typical
of all my noise samples.
It's going to have some
mean which we'll be taking
to be 0 and our examples.
It's got a variance
sigma squared.
So if a random variable
has this particular PDF,
we call it Gaussian.
That's the definition of a
Gaussian random variable.
The number here,
while you've got
to remember it at some
point, but all it's doing
is normalizing to unit area.
So the key thing
about a Gaussian
is that it's an exponential
with a negative sign there
of the squared deviation
from the mean normalized
by the variance with that
extra factor 2 there.
So different choices of variance
will give you different shapes
here.
So the smaller
variances correspond
to the more peaked and
more sharply-falling PDFs.
So let's see.
How many standard deviations
away from the mean
you have to go before you
have very low probability
of reaching there?
Anyone?
There's no unique answer
to this, but yeah?
AUDIENCE: 3?
PROFESSOR: 3 is not about idea.
So let's see.
Let's take sigma
squared equals 1.
That's variance of 1, so
the standard deviation is 1.
So for the red
trace, by the time
we get out to the number 3,
we expect to actually see
a very low value for the PDF.
So 3 sounds about right.
Does that hold up
for the blue one?
Sigma squared is 0.25.
So the square root of that
is a standard deviation,
which is 0.5, so 3 times that.
So when we get out to about 1.5,
we should be essentially at 0.
So don't forget the square root.
The other thing-- actually, I
should have commented on this
earlier, let me show it to you--
on this slide that I
had, I labeled this arrow
here just schematically
to show you
that it's a measure of width.
But the tag I put on it
is standard deviation.
Standard deviation
is the thing that you
want to use when you
want to measure width
on a distribution.
That has the right units.
Standard deviation, the
square root of variance
has the same units as
X. If X is a voltage,
the standard deviation
is units of voltage.
It would be a mistake to label
a spread here by the variance.
You want to think in terms
of standard deviation
when you're thinking
about spread.
So you define the variance
and then take the square root
to get the standard deviation.
OK.
So for our noise in
this kind of setting,
in our communications
setting, we're
going to assume that
every noise sample was
drawn from a Gaussian
distribution with zero mean.
Just the same kind of
distribution that I showed you.
So the only thing that's going
to change from one example
to another will be the variance.
But for a given case, we're
talking about IID noise.
You're going to fix the
variance, have zero mean,
and all your noise
samples will be pulled
from that same distribution.
If you were actually looking at
data here for these excursions,
if you were actually
looking at what
the excursions from the
baseline are, and you wanted
in a numerical experiment--
in a simulation setting,
for instance, or in
a physical experiment
to get an estimate of what
the mean and variance are,
well, we've got very
familiar expressions.
You would take the sample
mean or the sample variance.
The square root of
the sample variance
would then be your estimate
of the standard deviation.
So we can come at
the same objects--
well, we have the PDF, which
is the mathematical construct,
but in an experimental
setting, this
is how you would go
about estimating these.
And there's a whole big
theory of estimation
that tells you whether these
are good estimates or not
and offers alternatives,
and we're not
getting into any of that.
We're staying
close to the basics
and close to what
makes sense intuitively
and what's essentially
used all over.
So now we have the
task at the receiver
of getting a bunch
of samples like this
and then trying to decide
whether what we're seeing
is a reflection of a 1 or a 0.
If we had 0's sent
from here, what
we're going to see after we
receive the noisy signal is
perturbed samples.
And so we're going to look
at a particular sample
and try and decide whether in
that bit slot what was sent
was a 0 or a 1.
I'm going to actually use a
scheme for illustration here
that's not the scheme
that I've suggested here.
Here, I suggested
something that's sending 0.
If I'm communicating a 0 and
I'm sending some other voltage
level when I want to communicate
a 1, I'm going between 0 and 1.
It turns out on the
physical channel,
if you've got a transmitter
with a certain peak power,
you're probably better
off using a plus V
to indicate a 1 and
a minus V for a 0
because you're using that
transmitter at full power
all the time.
So you're actually trying
to overcome the noise
as strongly as possible.
So that's the scheme
I'm going to consider.
I'm going to consider
that when you
want to signal a 1, what you're
doing at the transmitting end
is sending out L samples at
plus some peak voltage Vp.
And when you want to signal a 0,
you send L samples at minus Vp.
So this is what we refer to
as a bipolar signaling scheme.
So it would be
something like this.
This is the xn.
And this is what I'm
using to signal a 1,
and this is what I'm
using to signal a 0.
But in terms of
actual voltage levels,
this is minus Vp and Vp here.
And on the receiving
end, what I'm
getting at any
particular samples--
so I pick one particular
sample to look at,
and when I look at that sample--
let's say at sample n sub j.
So maybe I'm looking
in the j-th bit slot
and I pick one particular sample
time, let we call that n sub j.
And I have to decide, am I
looking at plus Vp with noise
or am I looking at
minus Vp with noise?
That's a decision.
I know the Vp's--
assume that we've taken
care of the scaling and so
on across the channel.
And I know the
characteristics of the noise.
I know that the noise samples
are Gaussian, zero mean,
and some variance.
So if I draw a picture
that's turned sideways
here in terms of the
received signal, let's see.
I might get something
centered around
minus Vp or something
centered around Vp.
If a minus Vp was sent, then
it's got a noise added to it.
The noise has a
Gaussian distribution.
So this is the
distribution of values
I expect if a 0 was sent.
So this is-- let me call it--
it's the distribution of Y--
I'm not going to put all
the attachments here--
if a 0 was sent.
Because my shorthand notation
for the density of Y assuming
a 0 was sent.
I haven't drawn a very good
Gaussian, but you get the idea.
And here's the distribution
of Y if a 1 was sent.
So what I'm actually measuring
is some number out here.
I get some number.
And I've got to
decide, did that come
from having sent a 0 and
getting this much noise
or did it come from sending a
1 and getting this much noise?
That's the problem.
So if 0's and 1's
are equally likely,
what do you think is
a sensible rule here?
Just pick a threshold
where these two cross.
Threshold in the middle.
So if the sample is above the
threshold, you declare a 1.
If it's below the
threshold, you declare a 0.
What if 0's and 1's
were not equally likely?
Suppose it was much more
likely that you would get a 1.
And suppose we're still thinking
in terms of threshold rules,
what might you want to do?
Suppose it's much more
likely that we get a 1.
AUDIENCE: Move the
threshold to --
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Move the
threshold to the left.
PROFESSOR: Move it to the left.
So you want to actually
allow for the fact
that most of the time
you're getting 1's,
and so you really have
to get close to the 0
before you going to declare a 0.
So your bias kind
of gets built in.
Now this is just thinking as
an engineer what you might do.
It turns out that
for Gaussian noise,
the optimum decision
rule in terms
of minimizing the
probability of error
is exactly a threshold
rule of this kind.
And the analysis will tell you
where that threshold should be.
So we're not
getting into proving
that this is the
optimum, but it turns out
with Gaussian noise, the minimum
probability of error decision
rule for this kind of
a hypothesis test--
this is a classic
hypothesis test--
is to pick a threshold.
Now that's not true
necessarily for other sorts
of distributions, it's
not true for the settings,
but for the Gaussian it turns
out it's what you have to do.
So let's just assume
equal prior probabilities.
So 0's and 1's come at you
with equal probability,
and we now have to figure out
what the probability of error
is.
So there's a slide here
with some computation.
Let me just walk
you through that.
We don't have to follow
all the details and you can
study it and more--
I mean, you can
study it at leisure,
but it's the same
picture I showed.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [? Sorry ?] [? to ?]
[? interrupt, but I ?] have
a question--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --the Gaussian.
PROFESSOR: [? About ?]
[INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that true
when the two Gaussians
have different variances?
PROFESSOR: No.
OK, I'm assuming-- OK,
the question-- the comment
was that this rule of the
threshold being the optimum
is not necessarily true
if the Gaussians have
unequal variances.
But I'm assuming IID noise.
I'm assuming Independent
Identically Distributed noise.
So the noise samples are
governed by the same Gaussian
right through, and
then this turns out
to be the optimum rule.
Thanks for catching that.
So you can imagine
the picture with--
suppose the noise
is very sharply
peaked for one of these
cases and very shallow
for the other one.
So there's high variance for
the 1's and there's low variance
for the 0's.
You might then anticipate that
if you got a signal way over
to the left here, you're
going to call it a 1, not a 0.
So each case needs to be
dealt with separately.
But assuming these are
equal variance, which
goes with the IID case,
this is the optimum rule.
OK.
So let me just
step through this.
What we're saying
now is that what's
the probability of
making an error?
Well, let me actually write
down an expression here.
So the probability of an error--
this is the general expression.
It's the probability
that I send a 0--
let me just say that this is
the probability of sending
0 times the probability
of declaring 1
given that 0 was sent.
And then there's the
other possibility.
The probability that
I sent a 1, and here's
the probability of declaring
a 0 given 1 was sent.
So it turns out these
are the only two
ways you can make an error, and
these are mutually exclusive,
and so what you're
doing is adding
the probabilities of the
two ways of making an error.
You can either have a 0
sent, and then the question
is, what's the probability of
declaring a 1 if a 0 was sent?
And then you have the
corresponding term
on the other side.
If P0 equals P1--
in other words, if
both of them are 0.5,
this is going to be 1 minus P0.
If they're both 0.5, then
you can pull that out,
and what you're looking at
for the probability of error
is just the sum of the
areas under these two tails.
Oh sorry, not the
sum of the areas.
If these are both 0.5,
you pull out 0.5--
yeah.
It's the sum of those two areas.
OK.
So 0.5 times the sum
of those two areas.
Well in the symmetric case,
these two areas are the same.
The area to the right of this
threshold under the Gaussian
here is the probability
of declaring
a 1 given that a 0 was sent.
The area under the
tail to the left
here is the probability
of declaring
a 0 given that a 1 was sent.
Those two areas are the same.
So you'll discover that
the probability of error
is just the area under
one of these tails.
Just the area under
one of those tails.
So that's all you
have to compute.
So how do we do that?
Well, as the area
under a Gaussian.
We write down the Gaussian.
Let's pretend that this
was 0 and this was Vp.
It doesn't make a difference as
far as the computation of areas
goes, but it makes the
expressions easier to write.
So I'm saying that the
area under the table
here is equal to the area
under the tail there.
I can do it either way.
I can either center the
Gaussian at minus Vp and look
at the area to the right of 0,
or I can center the Gaussian at
0 and look at the area
to the right of Vp.
And the way the expression
is written here,
it chooses to do
it the second way.
So what we're saying is,
here is the Gaussian.
It's centered at
0, so I don't have
to subtract any term off
that term in the numerator.
Here's the 2 sigma squared
in the denominator.
And I integrate it
from Vp onwards.
There's this
notation introduced.
Vp is square root of ES.
The reason is that
we're thinking
in terms of the energy
of a single sample--
or the power of a
single sample, they
turn out to be the same
thing because it's just
a single sample.
So it's just the notation
that's traditionally used.
But what we're talking
about as Vp there.
So the area from Vp to
infinity under the Gaussian
with the normalization
factor here.
Now this is not an integral you
can evaluate in closed form.
It is a tabulated integral.
Tabulated most conveniently
in terms of something
called the error function.
And so when you work
through the calculus--
and I won't show it to
here, it's in the book,
you might do it
in recitation, you
discover that the
probability of error
is this error function of the
square root of ES over N0.
N0's notation for
2 sigma squared.
If I translate that back to
notation we've been using,
it's just Vp over sigma.
So the error performance,
the probability of error
is a function of the ratio
of the peak amplitude
on the signal to the standard
deviation of the noise.
That's sort of the
square root of the SNR.
The SNR would be
square of the amplitude
to square of the
standard deviation.
So this is the square
root of the SNR.
And what does this
function look like?
We can plot it.
So that's exactly
that computation.
This is a simulation on the
theory overlaid on each other,
but we have 0.5.
This function is called the
complementary error function.
The C is for complementary,
erf is for error function,
and here's the square
root of ES over N0
which we had in the
previous expression.
So you're really thinking
of signal-to-noise ratio
along this axis in dB and
the probability of error
on a logarithmic
scale down here.
So as the signal-to-noise
ratio increases,
as a signal becomes more
powerful relative to the noise,
the probability of
error decreases.
Visually what's going on?
Let's go back to this picture.
When the noise decreases
relative to the signal, what's
happening is that these
Gaussians are getting
more peaked and they're
pulling in more tightly,
and so there's less chance
of confusing the two cases.
So it's as simple as that.
It's the separation between
these two levels divided
by standard deviation of
the noise that's really
going to determine performance.
How far apart are
these two cases
relative to the standard
deviation of the noise?
That's the square root of
the signal-to-noise ratio.
That's what determines
the probability
of error in this case.
OK.
So are we done or could
we be doing better?
If you think of what we did,
we looked at the samples
in a bit slice, in a bit slot.
We took one of those
samples and we carried out
this decision rule on it.
Could we be doing
better than that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We could look
at one more sample?
PROFESSOR: We could look
at more than one sample.
This was a little bit arbitrary.
It was conservative.
Why you often do that is because
the number of samples in a bit
slot is small and you don't
want to get near the edges
because you're little
worried about the transience.
You've got a long enough--
if you've got enough samples in
a bit slot and the transience
have died out, then maybe
you can just pick out
a bigger chunk in the middle.
And so that's what we're
going to think to do here.
OK.
So it's the same
setting, but we're
going to average M samples.
We've got L samples per bit.
We may not be confident
capturing all of those
were averaging because there's
some stuff at the edges,
so let's pick M of them.
Maybe less than L. Take M of
them and compute the average.
And I'm doing this just
for one of the cases.
You'd have to do the same
thing for the minus Vp case.
So the question is, what
does the average do?
So why did you want
to average them?
What was your intuition?
AUDIENCE: Because that would--
it [? would be ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: OK.
So here's the key thing.
If you've got independent noise
samples and you average them,
you're going to
decrease the variance.
If you've got M independent
noise samples from an IID
process, you decrease
the variance by M.
This doesn't hold if the noise
samples are not independent.
In fact, if one noise sample
equals the other, then
when you add the two,
you get something
whose variances is four
times rather than just twice.
So it's critical that
these be independent.
So if we've got
independent samples--
independent noise
samples from one sample
to the next and we
average them-- well, let's
just average both
sides of this equation.
We've got the average
of Y going to be
the average of these
values, which is just
going to be Vp again
because it's constant at Vp,
plus the average of W.
Here's the other
interesting thing.
We're not going to
try proving this,
but it turns out
that the average
of a sum of independent
Gaussians is, again, Gaussian.
You might believe that if you
think of the central limit
theorem.
You think of each
of these Gaussians
being approximated by
sums of random variables.
So the sum of these
Gaussians is then
a sum of just a larger
number of random variables
that should still be Gaussian.
So the sum of an
independent set of Gaussians
is, again, Gaussian.
So all I need to know
for this average W
since it's Gaussian
is what is its mean
and what is its variance?
It turns out if you
add up a bunch of zero
mean random variables,
you get something
with zero mean, no surprise.
And if you add--
if you take the average,
then the variance actually
drops by that factor M.
So what you're
going to do is take
the average of the signal,
average of the noise.
That shrinks the
noise component.
You have the same
kind of picture
but now with a higher
signal-to-noise ratio.
Now what you've got in the
numerator instead of ES
is EB, which is M times ES.
You're summing the
energies of all the samples
that you've taken.
And that's what we refer to as
EB, it's the energy of the bit.
All right.
It turns out that that has
all sorts of implications.
You certainly want
to be averaging
if you've got this kind of
setting, because otherwise
you're leaving all these
samples on the table
and not making good use of them.
So if you're really
getting ambitious,
you really want to be
extracting all of that.
Also, if you want to maintain
the same error performance
and the noise
intensity increases,
then you're going to want to
have more samples per bit.
You may want to slow
down your signaling rate
so you can put more
samples per bit.
It turns out in the deep
space probe examples
that we've been
talking about, that's
exactly what's happening.
If you look at Voyager
2, it was transmitting
at 115 kilobits in 1979.
That's the year, I
joined the faculty,
that's a long time ago.
That was near Jupiter.
Last month-- I mean, it's
gone past Jupiter, Saturn.
The other planet
I only like to say
the Greek name of because it
comes out wrong when I say it.
It's Ouranos.
And then Neptune.
So it went past all of these.
And now it's about 9
billion miles away.
It's twice as far away
from the sun as Pluto is.
But look at the
transmission rate now.
It's 160 bits per second.
So it's greatly reduced.
And the reason is that over
this extended interval,
the energy per sample
that arrives at Earth
is just minuscule.
I mean, it was small enough
to begin with from Jupiter
and look at what it does now.
So it's about 1,000
times less in power
and you've gone down 1,000
times less more or less
in your signaling
rate because you're
trying to put that much
more time in the signal.
So these trade-offs
are driven by trying
to get the same energy
per bit for a given noise
to maintain the performance.
As I was reading
up on this, there
were little references to
things that went wrong.
The only a handful
of things that
are listed as having gone
wrong, but they turn out
to be related to decoding.
So there was a command that was
incorrectly decoded and kept
some heaters on for very long
and caused some malfunction.
Here was a flipped bit.
This is one of only--
these are a few of
only a small list
of things that are listed
as having gone wrong.
But a flipped bit
here caused a problem.
You've got very few bits in
these computers to begin with.
Remember the numbers
we had last time.
So a flipped bit
can cause trouble.
OK.
Let's do one last piece here.
We're going to try and be
even less conservative.
So suppose I know
that when a 1 is sent,
what I receive is a waveform
of a particular type.
So the piece of the response
corresponding to this
has some particular shape.
Suppose I know that.
OK.
So nothing is constant here.
This is the actual
y of n sequence.
And then to this,
I'm adding noise.
So here's the thing.
I've got a yn which is no longer
just a constant plus noise,
it's some known
profile plus noise.
That known profile
is actually what
the xn is going
to look like when
it goes through the channel.
I should perhaps have
called it y0 of n,
but let's stick to x0 of n.
So x0 of n is known,
and we've got the noise.
The question is, do you want
to just be averaging or do
you want to try something else?
If I've got this kind
of signal received
and I've got the same amount
of noise added to each sample,
which of these samples
is more trustworthy?
Which sample do you
want to weight more?
I've got some amount
of noise adding
into all of these
samples, so there's
some standard deviations'
worth on each of these.
Which is the most
trustworthy sample here?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The one on the right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's the one on the
right because it's
got the largest amplitude.
By itself it has the largest
signal-to-noise ratio.
So if you're going to
combine these samples,
you would think
that you would want
to put more weight on the
sample that was larger.
So you can actually
formulate that analytically.
So we're going to combine
the received samples
with some set of weights an.
Here's what it's going to
do on the right-hand side
of that equation.
Again, when you take
a weighted combination
of zero mean Gaussians, as
you get a zero mean Gaussian.
So all you need to know is
what's the variance of a scaled
Gaussian?
So let's see.
If I have a wn having
variance sigma squared,
what do you think is the
variance of 3 times wn?
3 times wn means the
excursions are scaled by 3,
so what's the variance?
9.
So scaling by a
particular number
scales the variance by
the square of that number.
So the Gaussian
you're adding in here
has a variance which
is sigma squared
times the sum of the W squared.
Sorry.
The sigma squared times
to sum of the A squareds.
That's what the variance
of the Gaussian is.
So you can actually write a very
simple optimization problem.
What choice of weights maximizes
the signal-to-noise ratio?
And you discover,
indeed, exactly
that you're going to put the
largest weight on the largest
sample.
And when you do that, the
resulting signal-to-noise ratio
is, again, energy of the
signal that was transmitted
divided by the variance.
So if you do the optimum
processing with this so-called
matched filtering, you're
going to get to energy
of the sample--
sorry, energy of the
bit over the noise
variance governing
the performance.
So it's the bit energy
over the noise variance
that's going to
determine performance
provided you milk that bit
slot for everything it's
worth by doing the
match filtering.
OK.
We'll leave it at
that for today.